there are the mvp odds currently
available at the points bet
sportsbook patron from home still the
favorite at plus 450 aaron rodgers plus
900.
hard to win it if you opt out for the
2021 season
and then everyone else in four digits
with josh allen and tom brady each at
plus thirteen hundred
big cat who who would you based on those
odds
who would you wager on for mvp do you go
with the chalk
or do you try to find somebody who's
who's kind of floating
you know in in a spot where it's going
to pay off a little bit more for you
i kind of like that matt stafford uh i
was like 18 to 1
because you you know he when it comes to
mvp it's obviously play but it's story
line as well
we saw it last year with russell wilson
this season started he was phenomenal to
start the season and he had the
storyline the fact that he had never
been voted
not a single vote for mvp kind of swept
the nation
he wasn't able to sustain his play but
if he had
been even like able to sustain it to
90 or 80 percent of what he was doing to
start the season
he would have been the runaway mvp so
matt stafford definitely is a storyline
guy
like if he starts out hot there's gonna
be pieces written about him
for about matt stafford about his time
in detroit about his switch to la
and you know his relationship with sean
mcvay i can see it right now
pull up the schedule whenever the rams
play you know monday night football week
nine i'm just guessing right in the
middle of the season
if they're six and two going into that
game
matt stafford will have the hype matt
stafford will start getting the love
that he probably deserves because he's
been a very good quarterback for a very
long time in the nfl
here's how i look at the mvp award and i
feel this way every year unless there's
someone who does something that
that sets an all-time record or comes
close to it like adrian peterson in 2012
when he almost set
the single season rushing record
typically it's the quarterback
of one of the teams that finishes with a
buy and now that there's only
one buy per conference available you got
to be the quarterback
of the one seed like aaron rodgers last
year
quarterback of the one seed in the nfc
or quarterback of the one seed in the
afc and
it's whichever of those two guys the
quarterbacks of the two number one seeds
who had the better statistical year
when the dust settles that's what it is
and it could be matthew stafford the
rams could end up being the one seed
in the nfc now i don't like their
chances when you've got the 49ers
seahawks and cardinals in your division
but but stafford fits the profile if the
rams truly are rejuvenated and
i mean look at how they did last year
with your friend jared goff
you you upgrade to matthew stafford i
think you're
i think you're kind of indirectly
throwing shade at jared goff
by putting matthew stafford in the mvp
conversation
i don't see how does he golf on the list
of odds anywhere
but but if the rams are the one seed
stafford's the mvp unless patrick will
holmes
has a better year and has that story
you're right the narrative starts
september october ish
and then the question is can you carry
it all the way through and once you
catch that wave it's like a surfer
one because aaron rodgers eventually
caught the wave in november
and rode it all the way to the end of
the season you get different chances to
catch that wave
and then the question is how long can
you ride it and the guy who catches it
in november or december and rides it out
to the finish is the guy who gets it
it's usually a quarterback from one of
the one seats
yeah russell wilson if he had just rode
that wave a little bit longer he would
have had
a legitimate chance um so i
yeah i mean matt stafford you can see it
happening already too that story that
came out where sean mcvay was talking
glowingly about matt stafford
i think that that's going to be a story
that a lot of journalists a lot of the
media wants to talk about
this guy who has had all the statistics
uh in his entire career going to a place
where you have sean mcvay a quarterback
guru
and a legitimate chance to to go deep in
the playoffs
i that people are going to be fascinated
by this add the lla
factor add the fact that la has the
super bowl this year
i'm i'm writing the story for you mike
there you go i just did your job
for you give me someone
off the radar out of nowhere
who you think could emerge as that guy
who catches a wave
and and rides that wave all the way
through to the end of the season as the
mvp
well he's not out of nowhere and he's
not off the radar but i do think josh
allen is a candidate for that because
you saw it last year
the bills became a story that people
were very attached to and loved
so if josh allen can duplicate what he
did last year
and he was phenomenal last year i think
that he will
the the the narrative is now there like
last year josh allen
arrived unquote to everyone kind of
coming to
grips with the fact that hey maybe
people were wrong
about their draft analysis maybe this
guy can be really really good
for a long time even though i loved him
and i love him and he's my best friend
uh but this is now the season where if
he duplicates it
it's like oh okay well he's gonna have
that mvp
talk week one you know what i mean like
if josh allen comes out
and throws let's say 10
10 touchdo let's say 11 touchdowns one
interception in the first three weeks of
the season
and the bills are 3-0 there will
absolutely be mvp talk with josh allen
yeah but then he's got to carry it out
he's got to ride it out and the patriots
are better this year
he's got to deal with the chiefs and the
ravens but and and we talked about josh
allen yesterday what's it going to take
for him to get to the next level
sims has him at number two behind
patrick mahomes can allen ever
overtake mahomes and you know he's got
to beat my homes and he had a chance
last year in the regular season he was
kind of flat and then they had the
chance in the
afc championship and he didn't pull it
off but he's got week five sunday night
football
against the chiefs that could be the
coming out party for the josh allen
mvp train but that's not really off the
radar all right i got one
i got another one okay all right i got
another one i don't know if we have this
clip
but a certain future hall of famer was
uh doing some type of exercise
training session uh where he was getting
beat up
in the pocket and counting out numbers
that's the one that's
only jameis winston that's
who i was gonna say yeah that's what i
was gonna say
you don't have derangement syndrome
that's good to hear jameis winston
uh similar to a matt stafford in the
you got the qb guru sean payton's there
can he work around the system he's got
guys to throw to he's got a system in
place
he learned it last year the saints still
have a very good roster
like you know could it be one of those
situations where jameis winston
uh you know is better than he's better
than drew brees last year so everyone
says oh wow well drewbies maybe was
really injured
like i've been saying for a really long
time hey big cat was right
but jameis winston would would be a good
candidate
out of nowhere mvp candidate first he's
got to win the starting job which he may
not do but if he does
we know what sean payton can do from you
hey you're glorified tight end your
little gadget guy
we we know what sean payton can do with
a quarterback we know how he goes about
constructing an offense and getting the
most out of the players that he has
the saints have been consistently good
year in and year out
and winston has a 5 000 yard passing
season and there aren't many guys in the
history of the nfl who have done that
and
i i made this argument to peter king on
a friday several weeks ago
you look at who jameis winston was
coached by he had dirk cutter for the
first three or four years who
currently is not in the nfl and then he
had mr no risk it no biscuit gee the
year he threw
30 interceptions and 5 000 yards and 35
touchdown passes
his coach was no risk at no biscuit what
a shock he threw 30 interceptions when
you're hearing no risk get no biscuit
every single day of the season you put
him with peyton
who's going to make it more careful and
deliberate and strategic
and not no risk it no biscuit i i
i i'm with you i don't know what the
jameis winston odds are
but you could probably make some money
if you're willing to drop 100 or so
on james winston you're probably gonna
have that flip into something big if he
ends up being the guy
don't forget to throw in the fact that
he just got lasik he can see now
he was playing quarterback blind in the
nfl
he's actually the greatest blind
quarterback of all time i'm confidently
gonna say that
so jameis winston was exceptional
numbers-wise for his first five years of
his career four years of his career
and he actually couldn't see he couldn't
see the middle linebacker
he he he went and got lazy lasik he
should have been wearing glasses the
whole time
he should have been doing the rec specs
now he can see watch out world
jameis winston future hall of famer
60 to one are the points bad odds for
james same as tua
same as tua i would go winston over two
in a heartbeat i love
but but i i gotta see it from tool
before i'm gonna believe it hell there's
a chance deshawn watson's gonna be the
week one starter in miami anyway this
year
where's that coming from mike is there
another another
just thing you read yeah how many
documents did you get through to read
that
to get to that conclusion go ahead and
scoff go ahead and skype i'm just asking
where'd it come from remember where you
heard it
i'm just telling you just remember where
you heard it if it happens it's all i'm
saying
there's no there were no high level dogs
and if it doesn't the product of staying
on top of the story every single
day for three months if it doesn't then
we just keep moving i'm not saying it's
gonna happen
i'm just saying that one of the
impediments to a winning mvp
is the dolphins not acquiring desean
watson that's all i'm saying
that would clearly be an impediment to
two of being the mvp if deshaun watson
is the starter
i'll just say it deshaun watson's gonna
be the week one start of the miami
dolphins there i
actually had the fortitude to say that
so when it happens credit me
this guy not mike florio offensive
rookie of the year yeah uh no i'm not
gonna say it
okay i'll say it no i'm not gonna say it
best
uh odds uh for winning offensive rookie
of the year trevor lawrence is plus
275 justin fields plus 500 trey lance
plus 700 zach wilson plus
800. i know who i like and it's none of
those guys
i i i naughty now i don't know how i
feel about naji harris after david
dicastro got cut by the steelers
yesterday but i've been saying najee
harris all along
it's big and he's not even on that board
where's kyle pitts
oh quarterback's only quarterbacks only
oh this is
sorry quarterbacks only all right cause
i was just saying kyle pitts is going
is gonna win offensive rookie of the
year i'll just throw that out there
right now he's going to win
wow yeah there's another one i just
think he's
he is ready to go right away he's going
to catch a lot of balls he's going to
put up crazy numbers
and we always see it like the you know
you can have those
impact rookies that running back a wide
receiver who come in
and make a big splash right away and and
everyone like everyone's like oh my god
this guy is incredible so
i i think kyle pitts will win offensive
rookie of the year
i don't think a tight end has ever won
offensive rookie of the year i don't
think that's ever happened he's
he's ten to one to perfect to win it and
with julio jones not there
gotta throw the football to somebody i
just think that offensive rookie of the
year
uh the more you have the ball in your
hands the better the chance you have to
win it and i think a
you know running back can generate the
stats rook quarterback obviously the
running back can generate the stats
quarterback's got to be a week one
starter how many of these guys are going
to be week one starters
that's a problem justin feels we we
don't think he's gonna be the week one
starter do you think he's gonna be the
week one starter
i'm just saying from the standpoint of
of having the opportunity to rack up the
kind of numbers that will get you the
votes now last year it worked for justin
herbert
because he he got on the field week two
and he was great and joe burrow got
injured but uh
of the quarterbacks i would tend to
think that zach wilson
would have the best chance just because
he will be the week one starter
and if he is as good or even close to as
good as sims seems to think he is and
from what i've seen he does have some
special skills
you know the new york market you helped
turn a team around that's been bad for
so long
i could see wilson building some buzz
he's gonna have to get you know
three four thousand yards passing but he
looks like a guy who can do it to me
yeah i'd agree with you there just
because we you know it's similar to the
mvp conversation the narrative behind it
trevor lawrence is already kind of
expected to be a franchise quarterback
forever
so he the expectations for trevor
lawrence
are a little unfair right out of the
gate so you know if he
if they have the exact same numbers
their rookie season everyone will look
at zach wilson's season
as being better than trevor lawrence
just because of how we frame it
i don't know if you're trevor lawrence
do you like it or you don't or do you
not like the fact
that no one really is paying attention
to trevor lawrence at all it's all
justin fields and we're
going to see well and then you throw tim
tebow on top of it nobody's paying
attention to trevor lawrence
i i think he probably likes it honestly
i do i mean that's
listen i think urban meyer has a weird
obsession with tim tebow and i
i actually think they want him to make
the team but the theory that they
brought in tim tebow
to provide a media shell for the rest of
the team
especially their franchise quarterback i
actually don't
you if you could tell me you could
convince me of that theory
let's just say that i don't believe that
i don't believe that because look it it
it hasn't provided the media shell they
didn't make them available during the
offseason program they're trying to
downplay
the media aspect wait it has though
every jaguars story we just said
no one's talking about trevor lawrence
every jaguar story has been tim tebow
that's a fact well
and there still haven't been many jaguar
stories that's part of the problem i
mean
it is amazing to me how we have in plain
sight
a grand experiment of a lifetime college
coach
who is bringing decidedly college
football ways to the nfl
like jimmy johnson did 30 plus years ago
and
and no one's really paying attention to
what's going on with jacksonville and
we'll see what they do coming out of the
gates they won their first game last
year and then proceeded to lose all the
rest of them but we'll see what they can
do
that that could be a storyline that
takes off how trevor lawrence could end
up being
an mvp candidate if this works in
jacksonville but i think it's going to
take some time if it's ever going to
work
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports